now to china where the military has been
called in to
blast open a dam to help control
catastrophic flooding
dramatic video shows people trapped
inside subway cars
submerged in chest deep waters in the
city of zhengzhao
the flooding has killed at least 33
people
after the area saw a year's worth of
rain in just
three days raymie innocencio reports
the deluge took the city and these
commuters by surprise
trapping hundreds in subway carriages as
flood waters rushed in
the flood was too powerful and people
got washed away this passenger said
another person and i almost wanted to
give up because we didn't have enough
strength
but i used my arm to hang on
many struggled to get out of the subway
system themselves and back onto higher
ground
with no other option rescue workers were
forced to cut open carriage roofs
and pull people to safety before any
remaining air ran out
we smashed the upper part of the glass
to let some air in
otherwise we would have suffocated on
ground level
dramatic video shows a group of people
attempting a rescue
before the ground gives way beneath them
across this city of 12 million the
rising flood waters turned streets into
raging rivers
trapping drivers in their cars and
residents in their homes
around 100 000 people have now been
evacuated
china's military has now been deployed
to assist this video from state media
shows a nearby dam being blasted open
to divert flood waters away from the
flood ravaged city
but with more rain on the way what
climate scientists have described as a
once in a millennium event
could become even more common in the
future for cbs this morning raymie and
ascencio hong kong